c'est louis boutrin le premier
vice-président de martinique transports
qui a présidé cette première séance de
travail à ses côtés la directrice
générale de l'autorité unique
régine lebel ils sont accompagnés
d'experts en transport qui viennent de
l'hexagone
face à eux les membres du jem mosaïque
ce sont eux qui devront gérer
l'exploitation commerciale du tcsp et ce
matin le reboot rey a fait des
propositions par exemple sur le prix du
ticket martinique transport propose donc
un euro 45
l'aller simple du lamentin carey romao à
fort de france et l'amplitude horaire en
semaine de 5 à 30 à 20h30 le vendredi et
samedi jusqu'à 22 heures 30
reste alors le problème des taxis co qui
n'est toujours pas réglé la question des
taxis qu elle est en cours de résolution
et donc c'est un travail de longue
haleine puisqu'il ya un volet social
très important
c'est très bien pris en charge par
martinique transport nous avons une
réunion spécifique hier sur ce sujet et
donc le
la question des taxis est en cours de
résolution est et sera partiellement
résolu à la mise en service du tcsp qui
parce que ces propositions le jem
mosaïque devra les étudier et les
responsables de cette société devront
traduire ses offres en euros combien
cela va-t-il coûter par exemple de faire
rouler ses bus plus longtemps que
pendant la marche à blanc
en revanche côté ambiance de travail
tous semblent décidés à faire rouler ses
fameux bus aujourd'hui nous avons
travaillé dans un climat
à ses objectifs et que je dirais
fructueux parce que nous avons descendu
les problèmes qui se posent et donc nous
avons abordé ça avec un esprit très
ouvert et je crois que le président de
la commission quelqu'un le premier
vice-président de martine transports a
fait les choses correctement
demain nouvelle réunion entre les deux
parties à l'ordre du jour les gros sous
les membres du jem mosaïque réclame plus
de sept millions d'euros à martinique
transport pour la marche à blanc un pré
accord semble déjà avoir été trouvé à
propos du règlement de cette somme pour
le reste on ne sait toujours pas quand
ces bus circuleront à des fins
commerciales
peut-être dans quelques semaines